[Applause]
[Music]
bts and coldplay's ama performance was
out of this world the two bands joined
forces on stage at the award show to
perform their song my universe for the
first time together and to no surprise
it was epic
[Music]
that's bts skipping their signature
choreographed routine to instead jam out
with the grammy winners they even sent
some love to fans in the pit when e.t
caught up with the k-pop stars ahead of
the award show they shared how excited
they were to be performing for their
fans the army in person again we waited
this for
so
so long time so it's like a dream yeah
it's like a dream i mean we actually
dreamed of this stream so it's crazy
i mean like we're just here to have a
good time with the armies with the
actual people but bts delivered not one
but two performances at the amas and
let's just say the second one was smooth
as butter
[Applause]
[Music]
bts was originally set to hit the stage
with megan the stallion to perform this
remix of the hit track
so smooth like the car i ride even your
best party planner couldn't catch this
vibe big mouse and i make a hater stay
on a job and i'll be on these girls next
like the back of they buzz but the
rapper suddenly dropped out on saturday
explaining on twitter it was due to an
unexpected personal matter
megan added she can't wait to perform
with them real soon i did what i had to
do as for trophies bts did not go home
empty-handed they won favorite pop group
making it the third year in a row
winning the category during their
acceptance speech they happily thanked
their
[Applause]
thanks to fans you're our universe it
took four years to be
on the stage to get this trophy um thank
you so much
and actually this means to us even more
you